Chimpanzees can identify each other by looking
at photographs of their bottoms.
Vultures can turn a dead body into a skeleton
in under five hours.
The Northern Hemisphere is 1.5oC hotter than
the Southern Hemisphere.
A lobster's brain is in its throat.
In 1883, a man named Jack Ferry crossed the
English Channel on a floating tricycle.
During its restoration in 1982, the Statue
of Liberty's head was accidentally installed
two feet off-centre.
Wherever a leaf is in the world, its internal
temperature is always 21 degrees C.
In 1990, there were no roundabouts in the
US; today there are more than 3,000.
There is a 12% chance that a game of Monopoly
will go on indefinitely.
The crunch of a crisp or an apple in your
mouth is a mini sonic boom.
The 'Masters in Lunacy' were Victorian officials
who investigated whether people claiming to
be insane were faking it.
'The Just Missed It Club' was for people who
almost sailed on the Titanic.
Two weeks after it sank, it had 118,337 members.
At any one time there are 100,000 ships at
sea.
The first telegram—sent on May 24th, 1884
by Samuel B. Morse—read “What hath god
wrought!”
Blind people are twice as likely to smell
things in their dreams as sighted people.
There are 60 people in Venezuela whose first
name is Hitler.